would you then argue that the Western
push to help Ukraine has been futile I
think there's no question I I've argued
for a long time that we are leading
Ukraine down the Primrose path I think
that pushing to bring Ukraine into NATO
was a huge mistake and Putin made it
clear when we announced in April 2008
that we were going to pursue that policy
that he would destroy Ukraine before he
would let that happen and in fact that
is what happened is happening Ukraine is
already lost a substantial portion of
its territory and I believe will lose
more and it will end up as a
dysfunctional rum State uh so this is a
disaster for Ukraine I believe if we
hadn't pushed forward to bring Ukraine
into NATO that Ukraine would probably be
intact today there would be no war and I
even believe Ukraine would still
continue control Crimea